Amtrak's CEO blames a freight train
operator for its latest deadly accident
an engineer and conductor were killed in
the crash in South Carolina yesterday a
hundred and sixteen others were hurt
Amtrak silverstar going from New York to
Miami was carrying nearly 150 people
when it rammed into a freight train Kris
Van Cleave is in West Columbia South
Carolina near the crash Kris good
morning good morning this is the third
deadly Amtrak crash in less than two
months the train came down these tracks
after encountering a switch that was
apparently in the wrong position that
put the Train on a deadly collision
course drone footage after the collision
shows the damage derailed passenger cars
lay next to a mangled freight engine
Amtrak train 91 had just left Columbia
South Carolina at around 2:35 Sunday
morning investigators say a track switch
was locked in the wrong position
diverting the Amtrak train onto a side
track where it collided with the parked
freight train and derailed the only
thing you heard was just the train car
just shaking shaking shaking the seats
came up off the floor
the National Transportation Safety Board
is now investigating why the switch was
incorrectly set about 80% of freight
railroads across the country do not have
automatic stop technology called
positive train control or PTC installed
NTSB Chairman Roberts some walls a fully
operational positive train control
system could have avoided this accident
that's what it's designed to do
initial reports are the train was going
about 59 miles an hour when it struck
the CSX freight train take a look at
what that does to the passenger cars
they are off the tracks investigators
are now moving car by car inside there
as they are trying to piece together
what happened here and clearly it was a
violent collision killed in the crash
was conductor Michael Sela
and engineer Michael Kemp Kemp's brother
Richard said his brother's death could
have been prevented well somebody forgot
to throw a switch we're all human we all
make mistakes
so and it happened he forgot to throw
that switch
freight line CSX controls these tracks
the company in a statement expressed its
condolences and says it is working with
investigators but did not address why
that switch was in the wrong position
the NTSB has recovered the
forward-facing video camera on that
Amtrak train Gail a lot of questions
about the switch very hard to hear thank
you very much Chris